merci laurent la chronique vos études
c'est la chronique des stèles gouzy tous
les mercredis alors je n'oublie pas
qu'une bonne partie de la france est
déjà en vacances pour pâques
mais cela n'empêche pas que l'éducation
nationale à son ministre alors est-ce
que cela va entraîner des changements de
politiques et bien estelle gouzy a
demandé leur avis aux lycéens alors
j'espère que nous allons pouvoir écouter
stèle goody et sa chronique
j'attends quelques secondes donc pour
savoir quoi la wii question qui était
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale avant le 16 mars
chevènement qui est le nouveau ministre
de l'éducation à ce que vous pourriez
lui dire à rené monory aujourd'hui le
même avantage pour tous au départ c'est
tout pour qu'un mini d'éducation soit
vraiment différente il faut qu'ils
changent totalement le système active en
france est actuellement dans sa change
un peu lentement qu'est ce que vous
attendez la liste des questions pour
vous personnellement
rien n'est en rien pour moi j'ai 100
photos des choses pour des gens plus
jeunes encore beaucoup à faire don
ça va faire pas mal d'études de ruyt est
ce que pour eux ça peut changer mais bon
bah nous les réformes sont derrière nous
ce sont ces changements comme jean
pierre chevènement a donc cédé la place
à rené monory et en changeant de
ministre on devrait aussi changer de
politique
c'est en tout cas ce qu'annonce le
programme signé le 16 janvier par l'udf
et le rpr
un programme qui prévoit plusieurs
réformes notamment éliminé la carte
scolaire pour permettre aux parents
d'inscrire leurs enfants dans
l'établissement public ou privé de leur
choix établissements dont les résultats
une fois évalués seront rendus publics
mettre en place un système de contrôle
de connaissances destiné à vérifier le
niveau des élèves avant leur passage en
6e et en seconde
enfin abroger la loi savary pour
accorder aux établissements
d'enseignement supérieur une autonomie
totale
le programme prévoit même de créer des
universités privées